[Music]
hey everybody its Charlie this is gonna
be my flash episode 18 video right after
the episode people were just tweeting me
gifts of people crying like just
reacting to that big twist I feel like
it was probably one of the better
episodes of this season there was a
whole bunch of foreshadowing for the
rest of the season some of you probably
picked up on some of the visual Easter
eggs too like on the metahuman bus so
I'll try to explain everything if you're
finding me for the first time be sure to
subscribe to get all the videos remember
we're almost at the finale pour out a
bottle your finest jingled for elongated
man nice of them to bring that back a
couple times during the episode but
number 10 on bus number 405 so this is
them just going back to the scene of the
crime so to speak to investigate full
dead man there's a poster on the wall
here I believe it's pronounced ochio a
it is basically foreshadowing for the
samurai attack later on I don't know if
it had any deeper significance than that
but it's just a specific Japanese art
style and I think that was just supposed
to be a visual reference but it really
tees up the big lesson of the episode
that we do not kill people so that
becomes a big runner but it's kind of a
red herring when you find out the real
reason why Ralph is so dead set on
putting the thinker down the other thing
here is that you get that flashback
which is kind of funny shows you how far
Ralph has come also sort of teeing up
the emotional twist at the end because
they really want you to care about Ralph
so they show you what a douchebag he is
berry makes a very meta reference later
in the episode where he says we like the
new Ralph we don't want him to go away
that's like the show being really
self-aware about what a douchebag the
Ralph's character was at the beginning
of the season he was a creep oh he was
making all kinds of weird comments about
the women's bodies now he's like a
genuine hero he's come so far you did an
amazing job of teaching him which is why
the twist is so effective at the end of
the episode the other really big thing
too is this season I've gotten so many
questions about the bus driver people
would talk about the 12 bus metas what
about the bus driver does that make him
a meta - they don't give you any answers
about that but you finally actually see
him in the flesh so you know that there
was a bus driver so it just throws a
little more fuel on that fire I think
for the most part the point of this
episode was to get rid of the metahuman
chase aspect he's got all the powers
he's got the dark matter that he needs
so now it's just team flash
trying to stop him from bringing his
plan to fruition and finding a way to
save Ralph
number nine was the sonic scepter sort
of teeing up the Harrison wells art but
all I could think about when Cisco said
the most powerful tuning fork in the
multiverse was the cosmic tuning fork
built by Alexander Luthor during
Infinite Crisis that was used to
recreate the multiverse number eight you
get that funny introduction to folded
man it reminds me of a scene during
infinity war that I will not
specifically talk about here because I
think people are trying to avoid
infinity war spoilers if you really do
want to know what that was just look at
my Twitter feed but it's exactly like a
moment during infinity war it was just
kind of funny haha because they're
making all these Marvel references like
they made a Thor son of Odin reference
after they fought they go to their
version of Burning Man like a just hippy
commune in the woods off the grid before
he became a meta so there's just a lot
of like funny moments so that you're off
guard when the samurai attacks number
seven of course was that samurai attack
he rushes Caitlin off and we learn all
about how she's learning to control her
powers she's got this really effective
tool the funny thing about that too was
the twist at the end with melting pots
powers oh you just figured the power's
out but now they're completely gone
Barry catching her midair in rushing her
away also reminded me of when he saved
her from Ronnie going nuclear back
during season one we haven't seen a lot
of Barry and Caitlin because they've
been drilling down so much on Barry and
iris getting married this season
thinking about that coffee shop girl
stuff so there just hasn't been as much
Barry Caitlin scenes because they've
been setting up a big payoff with Barry
and iris at the end of the season I
think but number 6 was Harrison wells
being totally addicted to the thinking
cap I feel bad for Cisco in his
enterprise model obviously Star Trek
reference they also made an x-men
reference to another Marvel Fox Marvel
reference when folded man was talking
about accidentally porting into
Professor X's lair he was in this chair
he looked just like Professor X from
x-men the thing I really liked about Joe
this week in addition to that badass
samurai takedown apparently he knows how
to use a katana now so do not mess with
Joe but the really big thing was the way
he brought in Francine back remember his
wife she was addicted to drugs that was
what drove her away from her family
while she was apparently pregnant with
Wally West but they kind of let you know
the direct
they're going with this Harrison wells
thing like he just addicted to it he's
not turning into the reverse-flash or
anything like that number five was Barry
versus elongated man I think people were
really happy to get that explainer
speech from elongated man later in the
episode that contextualized why he was
being such an [ __ ]
it's not because I'm afraid it's because
I'm so afraid for my new family the only
family that I've ever known
but on the way to that you have a couple
really cool bites so good special
effects sequence of Barry running around
his fist him putting the tuning fork in
his chest it's just a good way of
reminding you of the powers that he has
but I'm really happy that they didn't
linger on elongated man verses the team
but I think that's one of the reasons
why it's such a good thing from a story
standpoint that they did what they did
at the end of the episode so you don't
have to sit through the rest of the
episodes with everybody being [ __ ]
to each other number four team flash
Falls for the thinker's trap remember
the thinker anticipated everything that
happened in the episodes so knew that
the samurai would attack in cause
elongated man to do what he did that
would lead to the domino effect of team
flash eventually trying to enter the
thinker's lair so we get a die-hard
reference we get a couple of you know
badass moments with the characters but
really this is all build-up to turn STAR
Labs purple which is actually a really
cool effect even though it's a really
simple one you're just like oh [ __ ] so
number three it winds up being the B
team versus the thinker and his wife
round one is elongated man versus the
dinosaur that she grows and then
animates with her powers so it was a
good take down they give him this hero
shot it kind of lingers on him for a
second which is them showing you
superhero Ralph like the standard hero
shot that you give big superhero
characters in movies round two was Joe
versus the samurai which mostly takes
place off of scream but I love the way
that they set that up so it's even a big
stunt just to get them into that moment
because the samurai throws it sword at
Joe and he just reaches behind it
without even looking and Yanks it out of
the stone and comes after it round three
I think is probably the best fight
because it's iris versus Marley's and
she taunts her with who cares the most
about their husband all of you big iris
West stands probably went crazy for her
in this episode one of the best iris
episodes I do think you know if you are
a really big iris west fan I actually
I'm expecting some bigger twists in the
finale like their foreshadowing a lot of
things with these storylines I think
they'll pay that off so if you think
this is a really big moment for her like
just taking the sword to take down
Marley's great fight scene there's
something even bigger coming for her
character obviously on the other side of
that you have Harrison wells that over
juices himself with dark matter and it
blows up disabling him a little bit this
probably going to be some permanent
damage but they don't really address it
during the episode other than him being
slightly unfocused when they're
examining Caitlyn come on Harry focus
and he's kind of puttering around there
is something seriously wrong with him
but there was just too much other stuff
going on in the episode to really focus
on it so we'll probably learn more about
what happens with that in next week's
episode but remember what happens to
addicts when they don't take their drugs
anymore their bodies start going into
withdrawal so just expect some really
messed-up Harrison wells the next couple
of episodes till they fix his brain but
number two of course the thinker gets
the remaining two busts Mehta's takes
melting pot two people were like where's
the melting pot character we haven't
seen him in a little while he was in the
pipeline prison so when ralph walks up
he's just finishing taking those
remaining powers before he then takes
Ralph's powers forcing team flash to
watch remember he's controlling all the
technology so he turns the monitor on so
that the people like iris and everyone
else in the control room have to watch
him take Ralph's powers which is what
makes it so much more heartbreaking
because you actually have to watch it
happen if that wasn't enough though at
the same time he also says melt when he
holds out killer frost
so he's taking all of the metahuman DNA
out of her so there's no more killer
frost effectively dead until we find a
way to restore people but remember we
like elongated man we hope that he comes
back next season in some way so what
they might do in the next couple of
episodes is find a way to restore people
back to their bodies but obviously the
big moment of the episode was number one
where Ralph thinker turns back into Neal
salyanz' thinker it's a younger version
of himself and since he can make himself
look like whatever he wants he has the
darker hair he has the haircut he's not
all frazzled looking but remember even
though this is great payoff for his
character in it's really crazy moment
think about all the demented stuff that
he's been doing Tamar leaves his wife
this whole time
but also he reveals the enlightenment
device just looking at the schematic it
seems like it either generates some sort
of field or blows up has some sort of
area of effect that will upgrade
enlighten everyone's minds as he says
put the remember this is supposed to be
for the entire planet so let me know in
the comments what did you think of the
episode what was your favorite moment
and how do you think they're going to
defeat the thinker I think episode 20 is
supposed to be another coffee shop girl
episode but I'll post my trailer video
tomorrow
black lightnings finale is tonight so I
will try to do a black lightning finale
video tomorrow sometime but
congratulations to the latest giveaway
winner morgue 13:30 please private
message me so I can get your contact
details click here for Holly Quinn in
the birds of prey movie and click here
for brand new infinity war thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight